[Music]
so
it's now time to move on to our first
panel and we're going to be looking at
uh how the nhs needs to restructure
and retain its staff in the wake of the
continuing challenges of
david 19 as it prepares for a winter
crisis as it works its way through
this second wave and also looks forward
uh into the future there was a workforce
crisis before kovite 19
uh ever came along with a e waiting
times
the longest on record uh and many
patients struggling to access essential
hospital services there was a shortfall
of
100 000 staff within the nhs
and that meant that medical cover
regularly went unfilled and
stress-related absences amongst the
staff
rose but even as we get a handle on this
virus a backlog of non-coveted patients
has built up with serious conditions so
the challenges of the second wave the
winter crisis
it's all there looming over the nhs so
what does the nhs of the future need to
look like
to meet that patient demand and demand
going into the future
how do we challenge some of the
inequalities
in health care and provision that was so
brutally exposed
during the covet 19 pandemic
and how do we support that exhausted
workforce who
we so happily and proudly clapped for
but in effect
are working into the ground is that just
tough because that's what they signed up
for or can we perhaps do
a little bit better delighted to be
joined
to discuss that and more i'm sure by
richard murray
who's the chief executive of the kings
fund
by anita charlesworth who is the
director of research and economics at
the
health foundation and by danny mortimer
who's the chief executive
of nhs employers uh good morning and
welcome to
all of you let's start by looking at
staff
nursing and midwifery the standout
shortages
but 100 000 in anyone's money
is a massive gap uh
danny mortimer
it is alistair and i think um as you
said that the problems that we faced
were there before
the pandemic um the uh
response we've seen uh from the recent
spending review
and anita is able to talk far more
expertly than i about this
is insufficient i think there is a sense
in which we still need
a significant stepping up of investment
in the education pipeline
amongst those hundred thousand vacancies
that you've described
are a huge number of degree qualified um
staff and those staff need
uh teaching and educating in our
university sector and we need to see
significant investment
both through health education england
and through the office for students
in encouraging people to come and join
us and i guess that's one of the
positives that we
we are seeing is a real increase
uh an interest in working in health and
social care because of the
profile that it's had during the
pandemic but we we need to capitalize on
that and we need the government to be
prepared to invest
longer term uh in uh as i said
increasing that
that pipeline of okay i'll i'm gonna
come to
towards investment at the end as it were
having
laid out some of the challenges but i i
i note that point very clearly and
um and let me come to richard because
one of the things that that struck me
richard in this is that that a key
lesson of the
covid19 pandemic is that you can't do
the rest
when you're doing a pandemic
absolutely right and of course one of
the responses when the pandemic first
hit was to shut down
most of the services that could be shut
down to devote
everything on to the pandemic and i
think that's one of the lessons we've
learned is to try and keep
routine services going for as long as we
can i think one of the other things
we've learned though
um to touch on the workforce issue is
just to look to a wider group of
partners as well one of the strengths
we've seen here is some of the much
closer working between people in the
voluntary sector
outside of hospitals sometimes inside
hospitals too let's help people stay
well and stay connected help them get
out of hospital and stay home so as
difficult as the situation within the
nhs
is there are some hints here about the
way in which the nhs by working with
that wider group
i mentioned the voluntary sector of
local government with social care
employers too are you
that's a crucial point because we all
know that
you know whether it's the women's
institute bringing around tea trolleys
or whether it's local children's care
groups raising money for
i don't know special needs maternity uh
and
postnatal wards and what have you that's
because it's good men and women doing
good stuff
are you suggesting that needs to be more
formalized because we've learned
we can only do it on the basis of of
doing right stuff or do we just hope
that good folk are still out there
you do hope that good focus still out
there and of course they are and i think
we've seen through cover just how much
willingness um there is to try and help
the nhs
also to help their neighbors and people
in their community what we want is to
try and build up those links
between the statutory services like the
nhs and of the local government
and those groups try and work together
as one so
those groups will know when patients are
coming out of hospital they'll have a
better sense of who might be vulnerable
but
my point of view retaining the voluntary
word at the heart of it rather than
formalizing it yes yes okay
let me bring any because anita you've
written that without reform and
rethinking
and richard just spoke eloquently to the
rethinking
and danny started us off talking about a
degree of reform
but you have said without reform and
rethinking that shortfall of 100 000
staff will double and you say training
and pay are key absolutely and i think
we have a opportunity at the moment
where obviously people have seen how
important the nhs
is the numbers applying to key roles
like
nursing have increased significantly
and on the back of what happened this
summer with the a levels
we've got a an increase in the numbers
training to be nurses
training to be doctors this year we need
to make sure that that isn't a one-off
blip
and just this strange covert year but
that's a new
that's a change trajectory but it's not
just the degree level occupations
and we also need to think about how the
nhs and the social care system
can buy make a contribution to solving
some of the wider problems that kovid
will have created
you know opportunities for young people
in employment
are going to be significantly hit by the
recession
that will go on beyond this year
when you talk about conditions i i mean
i can i can understand
the retraining bit and and the
rethinking
but conditions of employment so for
social don't have a staff shortfall
unless people
resign walk out don't sign up
so there there are a couple of different
things so so we've got
in social care in particular we've got
an
issue where we have a workforce that are
very low paid often minimum wage
very high rate of zero hours contracts
so a quarter of zero hours contracts
there's quite a bit of research now
emerging
that those employment conditions in
social care
were associated with some of the spread
so of uh covid in our care sector
so that employment model didn't work
for a large number of the staff who
worked in social care
and also left us vulnerable when we had
the pandemic so and social care workers
have had some of the highest mortality
of any group in the workforce so for all
of those reasons we do need to
profoundly rethink social care
uh terms and conditions and it's over a
million people who work in social care
you know and also i want to add into
this
there's a national issue of shortage but
there's also a really important
geographical dimension to some of the
shortages
and kovic 19 has impacted disadvantaged
communities
most and in many cases disadvantaged
communities have some of the
struggle most to recruit and retain
health care workers so for example
there are fewer gps per head of
population
when you're just for need in
disadvantaged communities
compared to more affluent communities so
we need to think about this
nationally but we need to also
understand the geography
of our staffing shortages let me
hold that thought i'm going to come back
to you danny in a moment but i just want
to bring richard in
because anita has spoken there mainly
about nurses and
and care workers uh but richard your
your research has
has pointed out that nearly half of all
gps
will either retire early or go and do
something else as a result of the
experience of the last nine
months and you suggest at the king's
fund that a new model
of general practice is required so there
we have anita talking about nurses and
care workers
uh in crisis as it were and and your
king's fund saying
it's not that different in in the gp
sector
will a new model of gp work solve that
there is some um reasons to be
optimistic on the gp side
certainly not in the number of gps
that's that's the real problem
and of course gps are the cornerstone of
the way the nhs works
and where people get most of their care
is from general practice
as long as they've got a telephone and a
laptop or an or a pad or something like
that
well indeed or don't mind standing
outside of the practice
waiting in the wet in the way and if
you're 65 or 70 living in fear of your
health
and somebody says log in and i'll i'll
zoom you at
20 past nine it's it's not what they
grew up expecting
what they were expecting we have to
remember that hopefully as kobe recedes
some of that face-to-face work will
recover again and this is we're still in
emergency mode
at the moment what we are seeing in
general practice
is the large-scale appearance of new
professions so many pharmacists
many physiotherapists much of the work
that we see
going through general practice can be
done by by other professions
also link workers helping tie together
some of that voluntary work
with patients coming through the door
who may have social issues as well as
health issues
it's a really tricky thing to do because
you're redesigning the way
that a very long establishment right
that it can be done i'm going to stop
only because of time but but you set up
danny perfectly as the chief executive
of nhs
employers uh because danny the nhs has
has as it were it had a long-term plan
and then it had the people plan
and and and most of that's been pretty
well paused because of kovid
and uh as machiavelli said fortune is
the arbiter of half-hour affairs maybe
that
maybe that's a bit of luck uh the
government have pledged to more gps and
pledge to more nurses but everything's
on hold
when you hear anita talking about the
role of care workers
and finding perhaps a new type of health
worker to come in there somewhere
and you talk and and you hear richard
talking about
a new model of work for gps
does that chime with your thinking at
the nhs or
i mean you're aware of those arguments
but but are you
singing from the same hymn sheet now do
you suppose
yes and and and it it times um both
with how people are thinking but also
how people are working and we're working
before the pandemic the
the changes that have been described in
primary care
are still being distributed but but are
being implemented in many gp
gp practices um the use of technology
alongside face-to-face appointments
alastair i think it's a positive
and the scaling up of that will help
people access
healthcare teams where they where they
need to and but it is both and or into
both
and and we need uh we need to think very
differently about how we work
and there are some fantastic examples of
that during the pandemic
in terms of organizations running their
services very differently and staff
themselves generating ideas to do that
that's brilliant
um and uh we need to see
uh investment in social care
particularly because that's a really
important partner for
for our teams in the nhs we we care for
the same people particularly our
our elders and we also need to see that
kind of investment and capitalization
that anita described of interest in the
nhs we need to do all of those things
and we need to redistribute some posts
out of some of the more prosperous areas
particularly london and the southeast
where we see a greater concentration of
doctors
compared to where i'm talking to you
today in the midlands i mean all those
things need to happen
it's it's a big complex endeavor and but
the nhs isn't passive in this we're not
just sitting there saying well invest in
us give us more people
we are thinking very very differently
about how we how we deliver services and
i do think that pandemic has
has helped us in some ways think think
some fairly unthinkable things make some
fairly
radical changes that we we won't reverse
now in terms of how we work and deliver
care
and as i said to nadeem zahawi when when
he did the keynote address
let me ask you danny as well um
and you know working with people like
simon stevens and
and also the superstars that we know
from the number 10 downing street press
conference although
simon turns up there as well
occasionally um
is there a grid is there a time scale is
it
is the nhs collectively at your sort of
level now saying look
you know we've had nine months of this
we've now learned the lessons about
nursing i'm going to come to care on the
next panel but but you've introduced it
and anita spoke about it
but nursing care workers gps and what
have you um
here we are you know nearly halfway
through december
by the spring of next year we'll have
the first draft of
of you know son and daughter of of the
uh
of the long term plan and the people
plan is there a time scale a grid
in in simple terms the nhs wants to
you know carry on where it left off i
think the the comp
and deliver the long-term plan the
complicating factor now is the impact of
the pandemic
it's the delays that have been caused
you know the massive growth in our
waiting list it's also the additional
demands for our services
we're only starting now to understand
what covid means in terms of longer term
impacts the so-called long-covered
kind of set of symptoms and conditions
that people are having we will see we're
starting to see
growth in demand for mental health
services that will be exacerbated by the
recession that we are entering
and we know that from previous
recessions so those are the complicating
factors the other complicating
the other two complicating factors are
that the the long-term plan that was
announced a couple of years ago was
incomplete
there was no investment in capital there
was no investment in public health
there was no long-term investment in the
workforce and without those things the
ability of the long-term plan to be
delivered or the next iteration of the
long-term plan
um it's pretty tough to be frank and
similarly
the government's excessive governments
of all colors and combinations of colors
have promised a plan for social care and
that also
makes it more difficult for the nhs to
do what it needs to do
we we're going to drill into social care
in considerable
detail in in in part two as it were
but but before bringing anita and
richard back in to comment upon
um what you've just said danny let me
press you on what i think is a central
point
you said there was the long-term plan
and and the people plan
that was put on hold quite rightly
because of covid19 because
life-saving and health protection became
the absolute priority
and traced back to march and and since
then i
understand all of that are you telling
us this morning
that come the spring of next year all of
that work will simply be
reactivated because what i'm sensing
from rich and anita is you need a
fundamental rethink
you need to redefine what a gp does you
need to redefine what a nurse does
you need to redefine how nurses work
with care workers etc etc
is all of that in those two plans or are
you gonna have to get your pens out
again
those things are in those plans already
um and the
the desire to kind of continue
implementing the long-term plan was
resumed
in the summer you know our members were
were contacted and told to step back up
first of all anita are you happy then
that the
issue danny's just said that there are
they are within that plan
so are you confident anita that when we
get back to working on that
that it's the correct agenda and the
correct ambition action of travel is
absolutely
uh correct i think i want to
re-emphasize the point that daddy made
that actually a lot of that though was
not resourced
um before the summer and actually we
were expecting
with a new government if you remember
back we were in the at the beginning of
a new government
who were going to lay out their agenda
for this parliament and that was going
to include how they were going to
resource
enough doctors nurses other health care
workers
um there are some things that do need to
change
as a result of this as danny said we've
got new areas of demand
mental health we're already seeing
significant
numbers all the long covered we've got a
huge backlog of waiting
staff are exhausted but they've shown
that they can work really differently
so we do actually have a really critical
time
to next year to convince them
that it is worth staying in the nhs
and going on this journey because
actually it won't always be that they're
completely overstretched to drowning in
their workload and that's probably
the most important issue for them
before bringing richard in anita let me
be crystal clear for the folk
good enough to join us make sure i've
got it and that they've got it that you
two are content
that danny and the nhs team
reactivate the existing plan long-term
plan and people plan
but the one thing you say is a standout
that is in need of highlighting
is mental health and but also the
funding for the additional
i'm not going to talk about funding yet
that's my last subject
save your beer voucher arguments for a
moment but but that's crucial
so that the paragraph on or paragraph
the chapter or perhaps mental health
uh either needs to be added or needs to
be rewritten um richard
uh are you broadly content with the
papers
as they exist or do you think there's
something that's been left out or
that needs greater emphasis okay danny
danny come back in on that mental health
better integration
and don't forget that it's not only
hospital appointments that have been
delayed and that there's a build up and
a backlog
it's also in primary care and richard is
absolutely right there's a there's a
whole set of issues that that didn't
exist before the pandemic that
that will challenge the plan the
challenge that direction of travel but
actually
if anything make that direction of
travel even more important
and i think that the experience of the
pandemic has accelerated that that
collaboration and integration that
richard's described actually you know
we've we've done that we've seen the
acceleration also of the use of
technology
i think the other challenge that the
pandemic has given us though is that we
do need to
think much more radically about the
experience of inequalities
the fact that actually poverty and
ethnicity
became key risk factors in terms of the
disease in terms of the virus
uh have shown the nhs that it needs to
do much much more
in terms of addressing those issues the
nhs confederation that
i run at the moment is establishing the
race and health observatory for example
to try and target in particular
action to improve uh access
outcomes and experience for black and
minority ethnic communities and that's
really important
but there are other areas as well of
health inequalities that that were
referenced in the long-term plan but
that probably is the area that will have
the most radical
overhaul most radical thinking just
because the virus
has actually shown us the scale of the
challenge there is there
in terms of those very different
outcomes for different parts of our
population
and that's probably the area above all
that we're going to we're going to have
to target
but also just to underline that point
anita also
observed not only the the challenge
to to certain um ethnic groups
because of the way in which people live
the average size of family units etc etc
etc
anita also pointed out that that per
capita
there are fewer gps in poor areas of the
united kingdom
than there are in wealthy and
comfortable areas of the united kingdom
so there's a few things there absolutely
there are those issues about
how we've distributed some of our our
workforce over the years particularly
medical workforce you see
the phenomenon that anita described in
general practice you also see it in
terms of hospital services as well
much greater concentration of trainees
and
senior doctors in london compared to
other parts of the country and that
is an issue for us and i think the thing
we have to accept
in the nhs is that we are very we've
been better at designing services
for people who look like the four of us
uh then we have for
and have lifestyles like the four of us
and then we are
we have for the diversity of our
population so actually if you are poor
you find it harder to access our
services and we know that many
of our ethnic minority communities find
it harder to access our services
for all sorts of all sorts of reasons
and that just speaks to the fact that we
haven't
designed our services well enough we
haven't thought
carefully enough about how we provide
services so that actually those
communities
whether it's a poor white community or
an asian community in leicester down the
road from
me here in the midlands or an
afro-caribbean community here in
nottingham where i live
that actually those people have far
poorer outcomes than i do as a white
middle-class man
and that let me button on you danny just
because
i've had a i've got my little what's up
group here going and being
fed questions from people who are
calling in
um but this is an anonymous question um
but it
chimes worryingly i think with what you
were just saying there
hasn't the whole covet experience
demonstrated the failure
of centralized planning i mean in a
sense what you're talking about there
the need to address
the per capita distribution of gps and
gp practices
to poorer uh areas i mean is the nhs up
to doing that
so i mean to answer that question we do
have a very strong
um central um uh kind of direction of
the the nhs
and that redistribution of medical posts
for example needs that kind of national
intervention
but actually what we do need to see and
i think what we've seen during the
pandemic
is much a much greater ability for local
leaders to address the problems that
their organizations their communities
face
we are in my experience the nhs 30 years
and counting now
we are an increasingly regulated cr
increasingly overseen
service from from central organizations
and actually
part of the direction of the long-term
plan is is to try and ease that and that
is needed more than ever because we do
need to let
those people who are leading and
delivering services within the nhs
and their colleagues in local government
and elsewhere we need to give them much
greater discretion much greater
authority
to make the changes that will benefit
their communities because that cannot be
done
from a central regulator or from central
government
okay i've got one more general question
and then i'm going to
uh commit the the last 10 minutes or so
um
to to the investment issue and and the
penultimate uh
question and i will i'm going to stick
come back to you in a moment but i'm
going to go back to richard anita with
this one and then
again ask you as as nhs employers
uh chief exec danny to to comment upon
what they say
um so that anita first immigration
the the reliance upon the nhs in in many
sectors of of skill uh uh
but but predominantly um nurses and and
gps um
will that go on will it be made
more difficult with the measures that
pretty patel
uh has introduced and does that become
trickier or easier post-brexit how
in your view anita does that does the
whole uh immigration dimension
uh impact upon looking at a a better and
more fit for purpose nhs postcode
so i think over the medium term we
need to increase the number of
domestically trained staff
so that we are less reliant on
overseas uh workers to staff our nhs
that doesn't mean that we should have a
closed system not
that we're going to be able to available
our nhs over the next
five years is to maintain international
improvement
and uh we with the kingsford uh uh
have assessed that we need about 5000
nurses a year
now prior to covid we had started to
to to see numbers increasing um
obviously
covid with a lack of migrant flows it
has impacted that it's really difficult
to know what will happen
and i don't think the immigration rules
are necessarily the most important
factor
covid has changed i think for many
people around the world
their view about how small or big the
world is now and you may see
many people wanting to be closer to to
family and so we may see a wave of
movement
after that they're also though you know
going to be
a global economic hit and people are
going to be across the world
in search of good work um one of the
most important factors
for our ability to recruit uh overseas
workers just
and retain them just as much as domestic
is what's the experience of working in
the nhs like
how good is the pay in terms of
conditions and does it feel like you
could do a good job
so actually when you come back to
recruitment and retention whether it's
domestic or overseas you know the number
one important thing we need to make sure
is that if you come and work in the nhs
you could do it
you're supported to do a good job and
you get a fair pay
uh for that work i'm gonna i'm gonna
stop you on that because that point has
been made and i've done
and i'm no harm in making it again um
that's that's the way these things
occasionally work
but but i'm going to take from that your
main point being
that self-sufficiency should be an
ambition we were moving in that
direction kovid knocked it back a little
bit
um but we should continue to try and aim
for that richard is that your view as
well
um if i've got a caveat it would be this
isn't the first time
uh uk policymakers have aimed for
self-sufficiency
in either medical or nursing workforce
and here we are actually
more reliant than ever than coming in so
i think it's
exactly the right way to go the world is
becoming uh
rather more unsafe and it's the world's
becoming more competitive
so it's not only us that are in a
nursing shortage says the united states
and most other developed countries and
so the world's going to get tougher
to recruit from in the next few years
though we've got to recognize that
some of the answer on the nursing
workforce has to come
from international migration if it
doesn't come then it's going to be quite
bleak
that's it's one of the one of the things
that we can do rather more quickly
and so whatever pretty patera does needs
an nhs
kind of sense test against it make sure
that it doesn't get in the way
of bringing people in easily quickly and
giving them that good experience
that anita talks about so that they
actually feel that they're wanted
um rather than unwanted if they come
here it means they're not serving the
country where they grew up
and where they live and where their
families come from i've heard that
argument made in many quarters does the
king's fund
dismiss that argument or is it sensitive
to it
not at all we've got um uh overseas aid
obligations perhaps not quite the ones
we had a couple of weeks ago but
um there needs to be an ethical approach
to employment that might mean sometimes
that people come here
they also get some training while
they're here and then sometimes go back
again
sure and it should be done with the
agreement of the country that they're
coming from
thank you for that danny mortimer
self-sufficiency is a reasonable
objective but
uh you've always uh employed folk from
other countries and and perhaps you will
have to continue
uh to do so um
how close do you think the nhs can get
to
self-sufficiency way to go um to be
frank
uh alastair and um again i can reassure
you
is it a noble objective yes i think it
is
i think it is um the right objective or
albeit with caveats that that we we
clearly
do need to bring people in from
elsewhere in the in the world the
the experience of the the vaccine being
developed in germany by a
by a couple of turkish scientists um
and being you know developed and tested
by teams right across the world shows
that
that life sciences aren't kind of
developed in isolation in particular
communities and
and the uk as one of the leading nations
in the world in terms of life sciences
needs to be able to bring people in
to work in our teams and the history of
the nhs
has been about um men and women coming
to
prop up our primary care service from
the indian subcontinent about
women coming from the caribbean and
ireland to train as nurses in the 50s
and 60s and
we see men and women coming from the
philippines and india again
more recently as well as from uh our our
neighbors in in europe
but yes we we should aim for for greater
sufficiency and again that speaks to
this need
for a better plan the reason we got
ourselves into the
mess we got ourselves into over this
last 10 years is that
actually governments weren't properly
committing to long-term plans and
long-term financial settlements to the
nhs
and there was this almost
wild assumption that somehow the nhs
would be smaller in the face of an older
more sick populations somehow the nhs
would be smaller and would
employ fewer people to look after them
we thankfully accepted that that's
nonsense but that was a consequence of
the fact that we didn't have a proper
plan
for the nhs and i guess it reinforces
also the need for a proper plan for our
friends in in social care as well
because we can't repeat the same
mistakes
uh in terms of social care investment
and the social care workforce
let me sum up on that uh on that
very very important chunk that
essentially
uh it is your belief danny that
the long-term plan and the people plan
are fit for purpose
um and the principle not criticisms but
but additions as it were that you got
from
uh interestingly the king's fund and the
health foundation both
very powerful articulate well-informed
um lobbyists as it were
uh is a clearer grasp of the uh
damage that is being has been done to
folks mental health as a result of the
pandemic and a preparation for that in
the future
um uh the need to have greater
integration wherever possible
uh in dealing with the backlog that's
that in hospitals uh
and in primary care uh and and that the
ambition
of self-sufficiency in terms of nhs
staff
is a noble one uh and one that is
however a work in progress
uh but that that that is what uh should
be the plan
so i'm gonna come to the final chunk
then
and uh i'm going to ask
richard murray first from the king's
fund
in your view does the nhs see her
majesty's treasury
as being a bottomless pit of money
that the nhs just keeps going to keeps
going to
without ever fundamentally questioning
its efficiency
and its modus operandi because that's
the impression it's often left with
uh out in in the public at large
i don't think the uh nhs thinks that and
again we've just spoken about
a decade where uh nhs spending largely
didn't keep
up with demand so um as bottomless pits
go it will felt pretty awful for many
people working in the nhs and we've just
spoken about the workload issues that
staff are facing that's because there
aren't really enough of them to deal
with the patients
that are there part of the challenge
here goes to what you think initiatives
can do i think
danny said it exactly um
the nhs cannot provide good quality care
to a population that is getting bigger
and getting older and sometimes getting
sicker
it can't do it on the same budget on the
same number of staff so if you start
from thinking well
the budget shouldn't go up at all well
then yes the nhs is going to keep on
coming back
it can't do anything else if you
recognize that like so many other things
actually spending goes up
over time you can then have a more
sensible conversation about well what
should the spending levels be
what amount of care are we going to buy
what kind of quality of service
do we want starting from the assumption
that the nhs keeps on coming back
because the budget keeps on going up
well
the number of people in the country
keeps on going up so of course the
budget for the health service
is going to go up as well it's it's
about how quickly it rises
it rises but if you take a fascinating
comparison
the ministry of defense they have a
regular defense review
where they think fundamentally about
what they try to do and
we no longer think in those terms about
the battlefields of
uh northern europe and tanks rumbling
towards one another
some with with red stars on them and
others with stars and stripes and union
jacks upon them
we talk about cyber war we talk about
the chinese we talk about
uh intelligence coordination etc etc
when was the last time the nhs had the
equivalent review
of what you actually do you mentioned in
passing
that gp work is fundamentally redefined
anita talked about
the need to think about a fundamental
new worker a type of worker somewhere
between
care worker and nursing in the nhs but
doesn't the nhs
need to have the equivalent of a defense
review if it's to keep going
and taking more money from the treasury
extent
that is what we saw in the london plan
it didn't do everything
it did do some elements of rethinking
what that model
would look like and that's where some of
the changes in general practice are
coming from
i think what is valid though is that the
world has moved on because of
covid both the challenges the nhs is
facing but also the level of ambition
about
how quickly the images can change i
think
like many people who work with the nhs
for over many years
sometimes the pace of change whether in
new technology or new services
sometimes seems to be slower than people
would hope but what we've seen over the
last
months since march is sometimes changes
at breathtaking speed and i think we're
about to see it again on the vaccination
program
what it's shown is if you get the
ingredients right
the nhs can change at enormous pace i
think it's that ambition
we need to come back to you to think
again for the next few years let me put
the same questions to you anita but
adding in that point that richard
brilliantly made there at the end
that that you can uh
be cleverly inventive whether you're
dealing with the vaccination program
under
nadeem zahawi or whether you're talking
about at oxford university working with
astrazeneca or whatever it might be
but you've got to bank those changes
you've got to bank those experiences and
not simply move on
to the next phase one of the things that
we see across the nhs
time and time again is pockets of
outstanding innovation
and people uh pushing forward and doing
incredible things what we often struggle
with
is spreading that innovation uh
consistently
and quickly enough across the system and
it's it's one of the
paradoxes of a national health service
that people kind of assume
that it'll be broadly the same
everywhere and
and it differs um quite significantly
and too often we what we see is pockets
of little cottage industries
one of the things i want to come back to
though is your point about defense
review
because i think this has reminded us
uh again and again that actually having
clear strategies
that are really well aligned is
absolutely critical to the nhs
and a couple of years ago the house of
lords had a select committee on the
sustainability of our health and care
system and they recommended
uh that actually one of the paradoxes of
the nhs is that
we've had it for over 70 years but the
way we manage
it is actually on an incredibly
short-term time horizon
and we plan our workforce to the extent
that we do
separately to the way we plan our
physical estate separately to the
way we plan our services and what we
need is some kind of body a bit like the
office of budget responsibility that
does this
now for the economy which is a bit
independent
which doesn't just you know look at this
every 10 years
but on an ongoing basis is looking at
how our population is changing how
new technologies are changing because
you know the vaccines have shown us
you know what used to take 10 20 years
in terms of
development we've done it a year and and
that is exceptional but actually
innovation time horizons are shortening
um
all the time and so we need an ongoing
capacity
to think long term but act
fast on the long term and across all the
different areas that we need to
uh in the nhs and i i hope that rather
than just taking this as a moment and
doing a one-off
we'll actually learn from that and embed
better planning and the shortage of
capacity at the nhs
was actually one of the things that made
it so difficult when covid hit
to manage that well to sustain other
services and when we look across
different countries
countries that have taken the biggest
economic hit are countries that have
taken the biggest health here
so the treasury you know kind of it's
the economy
or its health argument is utterly false
you know a really well functioning nhs
that's really efficient
it's not that it's
our public finances you know it's part
of being a successful global economy
the final point before i bring danny in
to comment upon what
what both you and richard have said but
but let me press you anita
on on the very point that richard was
making
gps have learned to do things in a
different way
uh force major they had to because
because of kovid 19
but but they have now become more
accustomed to using
laptops pads smartphones etc etc etc
that's more cost effective as well but
it isn't necessarily what
a 68 year old woman who's been widowed
once
uh or a young mom who's living on her
own bringing up a child
if that is the way forward and it saves
money
it requires a huge education program as
well because we pay the bills
absolutely although quite interestingly
the one service
that for over a decade has been entirely
phone uh or online is actually the
pension service
yeah so the first government service
that closed its offices
i'm not suggesting gps close their
office by the way but it is a paradox
that we do talk a lot about and digital
literacy is really important and i
i'm not but it's about the support you
provide
and it can't be just digital and we are
slightly in field hospital mode at the
moment you know we've had to
we've had to innovate very rapidly and
we do need to make sure that we learn
from that innovation
phase but we do actually very carefully
now adapt
i mean people are talking about this
we're all sat in our bedrooms or
whatever at the moment home working
most people are saying i don't want to
go back to five days a week in the
office
but most companies are also saying i
don't want to be five days a week with
all my staff at home either
it's that horrible word hybrid and we've
got to create our normal new normal
which is the best of both
okay danny lots to come back on there
but but let me start off by putting that
basic question to you
um whether there is a
sense because what you do is literally
vital not metaphorically but literally
vital
uh that there is a sense within the nhs
i will just go and
pick up the blower to rishi sunak and
the money will keep rolling in
that you've learned you now have to
trade efficiency
effectiveness and imagination for cash
i think the history of health care is a
history of innovation the the history of
my career the things i've seen in my
career are enormous innovation
people stay uh in hospital now for far
fewer days than they used to when i
managed an orthopedic service uh in the
mid mid 1990s so i i see my clinical
colleagues
uh innovating at enormous pace actually
yes it could be quicker
yes we'd like that innovation to be
spread more quickly but actually
the productivity of the nhs far
outstrips many of our private sector
comparators actually in the the pace of
innovation far out strips
um um that and you can see part of that
success in the fact that we're all
living longer in my lifetime
my life my life expectancy has increased
by over 10 years
and the simple fact is that successive
governments and it is successive
governments this isn't about
mr sunak it's about a succession of his
predecessors as well
have failed to keep pace with that so
that suggestion that anita made about
actually having something within
government that's dedicated to taking a
long-term view around health and social
care
to my mind to our members mind is
essential what we see
what we saw throughout the 70s and 80s
and 90s is a complete lack of investment
in the nhs we then saw a spurt from tony
blair
uh in the early noughties we then saw it
being paused for another 10 years we
then saw
um or longer 10 or 20 years we then see
a little spurt from theresa may
a couple of years ago which is
incomplete no capital no public health
no money for education no money for
social care
we need to stop that and that's yeah the
nhs is doing its bit our clinical teams
are
are innovating working differently
they've done it at a scale in this last
nine months that i've never seen in my
my career but they are constantly
finding ways
of looking after their patients in
better and more effective ways
what's your view on my notion of a
defense review equivalent a health
a health review and as anita said then
maybe
also the equivalent in parallel to that
of an nhs
office of budget responsibility so you
have an objective assessment this we can
do that we can't do this we can do more
productively that we can't do
and here are able men and women who are
objective judges of these matters
to keep an eye on what we do does that i
think the the
the long-term plan um did that in terms
of our our service aspirations we you
know we
we have to fill in the other pieces
there in terms of capital public health
and people
but that standing function within
government that office of budget
responsibility for health
seems to us in the confederation to be
absolutely essential
because that review shouldn't be a kind
of thing you do every five or ten years
or when the electoral cycle dictates it
it should be a thing that's being done
constantly so that we can keep pace with
innovations that we can keep pace with
the demands of a
of a population that's living longer but
is having more things going wrong with
it
all of those things are absolutely so it
can keep pace with the mental health
demand we're going to see from the
the coming recession it's that constant
appraisal of what's needed
and that constant advice to the
government about what investment is
needed to keep pace
so that the economy is as strong as
possible and i think
the particularly important point that
anita made was that an investment in
health and social care is an investment
in the health and wealth of the nation
it's an investment in our infrastructure
it's just as important as investing in
roads or hs2 or digital capability or
green technologies
it's part of what makes us a competitive
nation
and successive governments have failed
to do that they see it as something they
do
as a one-off and then they return to it
10 20 years later that's not good enough
it needs to be a constant process
danny mortimer chief exec of nhs
employers anita charlesworth
from the health foundation and richard
murray from the king's fund thank you
all
very much indeed some really intriguing
points there not all
easy-peasy agreement but some
fundamental stuff about uh
redefining roles uh in the wake of the
experience of kv-19 but also banking
them
and accepting that the long-term plan is
there but it needs perhaps to have an
overview body that is not
of the treasury or of the nhs but
something like the office of budget
responsibility that can
look at it that as you learn experiences
through something as ghastly as kv19
you don't just shrug them off and think
right we're back to normal next year
you learn from them you embed them and
through that perhaps comes
pretty fundamental reform and and also
self-sufficiency in staff should be a
long-term ambition
and progress is being made upon that and
thanks again to our sponsors
msd uh for making all of this possible
[Music]
you